So, to get a better sense of how timing works,
I've defined a procedure spin loop. Spin loop starts by
initializing the variable i to zero and then it goes
through a loop n times, each time through the loop is
just adds one to i. So that'll run for longer,
we can, by picking the value of n, make it
go through the loop any number of times. So, let's
try that. So I'll try running the loop 1,000 times and
now we get no result, and the time it took is 0.0001 seconds. So, about a tenth
of a millisecond. Let's try it with a
larger number of executions, so now I am going
to increase the number of iterations by ten,
so the value of n's multiplied by ten. And
if we see that now, the time is, is higher, the time is increased to about six
tenths of a millisecond and we can keep increasing
the time, so let's try looping 100,000 times. And
we see if the time increases. And the time
increased by about a factor of ten. Between looping
10,000 times and looping 100,000 times. And we'll try
one more time. Let's go for a million. If
we go for a million times, now we're up
to 0.05. So, five hundredths of a second, or
55 milliseconds. To loop a million times. Still pretty fast, right? We're going
through that loop a million times. It's still much less than a second.
What's important is, we can see that well, the time changes depending on
the input. As we increase the input
to spin loop, the time increases accordingly.